[Music]
I made a nano scientist at Cornell
University who had a really interesting
story he had discovered with his
graduate student how to make the world's
thinnest glass it was only one atom
thick the top of it was the same atom as
the bottom of it and he called the two
dimensional glass it was an amazing
thing nobody had ever found a way to
make glass this thin before and it was
picked up by one scientific journal and
it seemed like a more interesting
subject than then then one that would
you just get that much attention and he
a couple of months later he was taking
our workshop when we were up with
Cornell and in the course of talking
about his discovery we realized that he
had discovered how to make the world's
thinnest glass by accident it wasn't
something he was trying to do an
accident happened and I said you know
this is fascinating people like us on
the outside and the public it's an
interesting story to us to know that
something so groundbreaking that helped
you understand the structure of glass
and help might have new uses for glass
that you discovered such a thing by
accident what an interesting story that
is and also in the meantime he had been
cited in the Guinness Book of World
Records as World Records as having
discovered the worlds in his class so
now he had two things that would
interest the public and the next time he
gave an interview he started off with
the story of how it had been an accident
that he discovered this this human story
now led into the technical the technical
story about what was what was the
world's thinnest glass how was it made
and that kind of thing
it became a story that was interesting
to other people who don't know the
technical details with that familiarity
and now his story about this
the glass was picked up by websites and
newspapers all over America all over
Great Britain and venture capitalists
started calling I'm asking if they could
commercialize this process just starting
with a human story that people on the
outside of your work are interested in
because we're all human and we all
thinking stories and every experiment
has a story every life and science has a
story and it's so common to hear people
when you when you say for them in a in a
workshop tell me your story
you say oh I don't have a story yes you
do what's fascinating to you when you
really think about it about how you got
from here to there and the most
important thing about a story it turns
out to me anyway is the obstacle that
you found yourself facing as you were
trying to get to your goal the story is
not I wanted to get to Toledo and I went
and I got there that's that's okay it's
not much of a story the story is I was
headed toward Toledo when the airplanes
were shut down the cars were shut down
the railroad you should how was I going
to get to Toledo
that's an interesting story and I'm one
I want to listen to that if in the
course of that it turns out you
discovered a new way to get to Toledo I
want to hear it the glacier water
exercise is something that I figured out
on the way to giving a talk I wanted to
give a talk to writers about what what's
the essential ingredient of a dramatic
story and I'm in the car with my wife
and I said I don't know how to start
this thing she's a whoa why don't you
start with some image I said an image
okay okay so an image of a story a
dramatic story I decided in that moment
was carrying a glass of water across the
stage filled to the brim so when I got
there I said is there somebody
relatively brave in the audience come on
up carry this empty glass across the
stage and it's a little awkward the
audience titters a little bit but
nothing much is happening she puts the
glass down on the table over there
then I take a picture and I fill it all
the way to the brim as far as hardly a
molecule of water left before it starts
to spill and she's holding the glass and
I say okay now carry the glass carefully
across the stage and put it on the table
over there
but don't spill a drop where your entire
village will die now she's got an
obstacle chance to overcome and she
carries it so carefully so carefully
that the audience is riveted to the
glass and if a bead of water goes down
the side of the glass you can hear them
gasp now everybody knows there's no
there's no village nobody's going to die
but just just the imaginary situation
that she has this important obstacle
makes this an engaging site and that
happens in every story that has a
dramatic obstacle in it the attempt to
get past the obstacle to get where
you're going to achieve what you're
trying to achieve makes it an
interesting story so my guess is instead
of leaving out your mistakes instead of
leaving out the problems you have in
achieving something whether it's science
or whether it's an interview where the
the prospective boss says tell me about
your greatest achievement don't just
tell about your greatest achievement
tell them about the problems you had in
solving that the issue you were dealing
with so you could get to something you
could call them achievement that makes
it an interesting story it makes it a
more human story and it doesn't make you
a braggart it shows you you had
something really tough to work on here's
what you thought you might do to make it
better it's engaging and what you want
to do is engage that new employer you
don't want to just give them the facts
here are the facts you're to hire me
he's going to work with you we're going
to work with a person give them the
person and is that the scientist gives
the audience of person and how they felt
and what they
throw as they were accomplishing this in
addition an important discovery we're
going to take it in better we're going
to understand it better and we're going
to remember it
[Music]